seguimos con más información para
ustedes siempre las 24 y es tiempo
hablar de economía y estamos para eso
con daniela hablando con que nos va a
contar lo más importante hoy daniela
bienvenida los 12 multimillonarios más
destacados de wall street se han visto
beneficiados con la pandemia a cuadros
porque liliana muy buenas noches porque
alcanzaron por primera vez en la
historia una riqueza combinada de 13
cifras es decir más de un billón de
dólares de patrimonio esto según una
investigación del instituto para
estudios políticos de eeuu que agrega
que esta cifra es un 40 por ciento mayor
que cuando comenzó la pandemia el
coronavirus
los más afortunados de todo son liliana
el fundador de amazon jeff bezos el de
microsoft bill gates y el de facebook
marck zuckerberg pero también aparecen
otros como warren buffett y iron mask
quien es el dueño de la marca de autos
de lujo tesla para hacerse una idea de
cuánta fortuna tienen estos 12 magnates
liliana pues ese millón de dólares es
casi tres veces el producto interno
bruto de todo un año en un país como
nigeria que es uno de los más pobres del
mundo en donde gran parte de su
población vive con un promedio de 2
dólares al día
daniela y hay polémica por la elección
del nuevo presidente del banco
interamericano de desarrollo sí señora
dentro de poco se acaba el segundo
mandato del colombiano luis alberto
moreno frente a la multilateral y la
elección de su reemplazo ha sido
bastante controversial primero porque
las elecciones están programadas para el
12 de septiembre sin embargo varios
países entre ellos méxico costa rica
chile argentina y hasta la unión europea
han pedido que se aplacen hasta marzo de
2021 debido a la pandemia del
coronavirus pero la mayor polémica en
polémica tiene que ver con la nominación
del candidato de donald
mauricio claver carone quien fuera su
asesor para américa latina hay quienes
consideran que nombrar a un
estadounidense aunque de origen cubano
rompería con la tradición de este que
este puesto lo ocupe un latinoamericano
y hay otros que apoyan a trauma como el
salvador haití guyana y hasta colombia
bueno y hablamos ahora la economía
chilena daniela porque cayó en el
segundo trimestre pero se salvó de ser
declarada como una recesión el producto
interno bruto de chile cayó 13.2 por
ciento entre abril y junio frente al
trimestre anterior la contracción
interanual o sea frente al mismo período
del año pasado desde el 14.1 por ciento
el peor resultado desde 1986 cuando
iniciaron estos registros pero a
diferencia de otros países del mundo
chile no entró en recesión técnica que
es cuando una economía lleva dos
trimestres seguidos de contracción esto
ayudó a que en los tres primeros meses
del año el pib había crecido un 3% el
banco central reveló que todas las
actividades productivas presentaron
caídas durante los meses más críticos de
la pandemia
las únicas decepciones fueron
la minería los servicios financieros y
administración pública daniela y
cuéntenos cuáles son las curiosidades
económicas de esta jornada
liliana la primera es coyuntural y
esqueda farmacéutica china sino farm que
tiene participación estatal ya anunció
que espera tener lista la vacuna contra
el cob y de 19 a finales de este año lo
curioso es que su precio estimado es de
144 dólares por dosis casi cuatro veces
más costosa que la de las de la
estadounidense moderna y casi siete
veces más que la que están desarrollando
conjuntamente la estadounidense paige
fighter y la alemana bayer trick y la
segunda curiosidad liliana es el precio
del pan en nicaragua hasta el fin de
semana una bolsa de 12 panes costaba 29
centavos de dólar pero el gremio de
panaderías que aglutina a unas 250
decidió duplicar ese valor a 58 centavos
dicen que esto se debe al dramático
incremento en las materias primas bueno
daniela muy curiosas estos datos muy
curiosos y cuáles son los indicadores de
la jornada wall street de marco doble
recortes en sus indicadores más
importantes
del nasdaq el standard poor's 500 superó
su más reciente marca histórica del 19
de febrero todas las principales bolsas
europeas bajaron en medio de las
tensiones todavía vivas entre eeuu y
china y en américa latina se notaron
fuertes contrastes mientras que la bolsa
de buenos aires se derrumbó más del 4%
la de brasil subió y finalizamos con la
ciudad al día 45 dólares liliana graves
esta cifra entregó el gobierno de
venezuela a cada trabajador
independiente registrado para
persuadirlos de que permanezcan en casa
a medida que el kobe 19 pues va a
aumentar con esa cantidad
liliana se pueden comprar en venezuela
casi dos cartones de 30 huevos o si
quiere también algo más de un kilo de
carne o un paquete de salchichas bueno
el ensayo mínimo entonces daniela en el
país por supuesto gracias por la
información de economía y usted gracias
por estar en plática de control en con
más en france 24 punto com
[Música]